this April this is my moment I've been
training since yesterday for this ague
show like no other it wasn't easy but
you know wasn't hard either paint the
best picture over force whilst riding a
horse pushing limits begone limits
where's the ball
testing the human spirit will that be a
open-book test put as many blue M&Ms in
the empty bowl as possible
[Applause]
and bringing glory to one champion there
gonna be any snacks
I get a bit lightheaded when I don't eat
five people enter I didn't come here to
make friends
that just happened by accident all five
leave do I want to win hell maybe no one
is voted on I'm 100% committed to
committing to this I think the stakes
have never been a voiceover guy
how about you tone it down a little bit
taskmaster that's me I'm the taskmaster
and on the task assistant that doesn't
exist new series premieres Friday April
27th at 11 who say bubbles for me no
okay thank you so much though